call of duty black ops cold war has been
officially
and finally revealed we got a surprise
nintendo direct mini this morning and
fall guys is now the most downloaded
ps plus game ever i'm persia and you've
reached your save state for wednesday
august 26th
we saw a teaser trailer last week for
call of duty black ops cold war
but after today's reveal event we know a
whole lot more about the game
cold war is a direct sequel to black ops
1 that will be set mostly in the 1980s
you will encounter characters from the
black ops series
but you will play as your own custom
character with open-ended missions and
side objectives and multiple endings in
the campaign
as far as multiplayer goes we know now
that you will be able to play cross
platform
and cross gin zombies is back to some
extent and war zone will continue to
evolve
with cold war's release which makes a
lot of sense considering the way they
used war zone to reveal their trailer
this morning
although we were hearing some rumors
about a separate nintendo direct coming
later this week
a surprise nintendo mini dropped today
called the partner showcase that
featured
some third party games coming to the
switch we got more info on kingdom
hearts
melody of memory which is the rhythm
game where you battle to the rhythm of
songs
from the entire kingdom hearts series
revisit iconic moments and more
melody of memory got an official release
date of november 13th and will also be
coming to ps4
and xbox one there were also some new
announcements like puyo puyo tetras 2
that's coming to the switch on december
8th and will have that same
puzzle crossover style but they're
adding a new card based skill battle
mode
and a new story at this point we really
don't know when the next direct will be
but if you happen to miss the mini and
you want to stay up to date on all the
future nintendo news then
make sure you go to gamespot.com we
already know that fall guys has been
taking the world by
storm but it has now become the most
downloaded playstation plus game
of all time if that sounds like a lot
then it's also worth noting that fall
guys has sold
over 7 million units on steam alone
developer media tonic has more planned
for the future of the game with upcoming
content updates a mobile version being
licensed in china
and season two being outlined tomorrow
during the opening night of gamescom
we'll be covering that in all of the
gamescom news so make sure you're tuning
in tomorrow at 11 a.m pacific
for everything you'll need to know on
that
thanks for joining me for your daily
news and don't forget about the handful
of days we have left
in our play for all donation drive
august 31st will be the last day to get
exclusive merch and help support black
lives matter
and coven 19 relief efforts so just go
ahead and go over to store.gamespot.com
have a great wednesday give me a follow
on twitter at persia underscore exo and
of course
meet us back here tomorrow for your next
save state see
[Music]
you